benessere a tutti non è vero che i
ricercatori passino le giornate a dosare
sostanza in provetta o scrivere formule
anche noi ci divertiamo ogni tanto io ho
scritto il testo per un pezzo canoro
musicale che in cui ho condensato
qualche mia idea sui problemi del mondo
non escludendone 1 puramente personale
quello di avere scarpe numero 41
a otto anni volevo fare il calzolaio e
fare scarpe numero 41
mia mamma le cercava invano nei negozi
io non sapevo ancora bene che cosa fosse
una gaussiana però sperimentavo già come
ci si può trovare fuori dalla sua
campana
adesso molte donne hanno il numero 41 e
io non faccio il calzolaio hanno deciso
medicina agricoltura il portafoglio
economia fallace e calorie sicure la
microbiologia e l'ingegneria insieme a
lavorare ma basta fermentare oppure
modificare si cammina di meno fra
macchine energia la vita si fa facile e
la calzoleria non serve molto spesso chi
pensa a camminare oppure alle termopili
quale tanto lievi avanzare in silenzio
nella rete bilanci energetici
intrappolano ormai la biologia smaltisce
con il fitness
e clima si impigrisce per le troppe
calorie e piove ancora meno oppure piove
di più le scarpe non si bagnano si
bagnano di più
la fisica la chimica giocano con noi
noi giochiamo con loro dipende da chi
vince la penso io
grazie
ringrazio i colleghi che non sono
musicisti sono anche musicisti ma sono
anche bravi ricercatori che hanno
gentilmente ha consentito ad essere qui
con noi oggi
beh dipende da vista chi vince alla fine
penso io
in effetti non è una guerra quella del
clima che cambia ma è come se lo fosse
io credo che possiamo dire di trovarsi
di fronte un momento epocale adesso
momento in cui veramente alcune cose
stanno cambiando tutto diventa di più se
ci pensiamo pensiamo un attimo
l'agricoltura che è il tema su cui mi
vorrei concentrare che cosa c'è di più
di più è il numero di persone che
dobbiamo nutrire di più quindi dobbiamo
produrre di più e sempre più grandi sono
le insidie possiamo dire anche le
minacce di un clima che cambia
contemporaneamente insieme a questo di
più quello che manca che sta diventando
meno sono proprio le necessarie risorse
che ne tesi sono necessarie per produrre
invece di più quindi l'acqua il suolo e
le energie non rinnovabili
l'agricoltura magari non ci pensiamo mai
però sappiamo è quella l'attività umana
forse più vitale più importante in tutti
i paesi più ricchi e più poveri e quella
a cui ci rivolgiamo per il pane
quotidiano ma è anche quella che ci
fornisce una serie di beni e di servizi
immateriali non tangibili di cui godiamo
tutti i giorni
basta pensare alla vita al lavoro nei
territori
basta pensare al turismo al paesaggio
alla bellezza al mantenimento il
miglioramento della qualità dell'aria
contenimento dell'erosione alla
stabilità dei suoli
quindi credo veramente che l'agricoltura
di fronte a questa sfida debba vincere e
tutti lo sappiamo veramente importante
perché l'agricoltura non è un optional è
un must cioè una priorità
io penso di potervi dire in un qualche
modo com'è possibile che l'agricoltura
vinca questa guerra per la vita ve lo
dico come ricercatore però ve lo dico
anche come vicepresidente della
commissione di agrometeorologia
dell'organizzazione meteorologica
mondiale che fa capo alle nazioni unite
l'abbiamo detto al cop 21 a parigi dove
erano poi mostrate anche le foto che
vedremo tra poco viene detto e scritto
sull'agenda lo sviluppo sostenibile 2030
e lo diciamo sempre alla fao e al forum
globale per la ricerca agricola che
spingono e stanno sponsorizzando
fortemente un'alleanza vera e proprio
per questo scopo
l'agricoltura per vincere questa
battaglia non ha un altro modo che
riciclarsi cambiare il proprio
metabolismo cabrera proprio filosofia
diventare smart intelligente in grado
quindi di adattarsi a un clima che
cambia
io dell'adattamento vi parlo tra un
attimo e vi porterò qualche esempio però
credo che il concetto sia proprio quello
che i nostri sistemi di produzione
devono essere duttili devono essere
strategici tattici e quindi modularsi in
un qualche modo al clima che cambia
in secondo luogo e questo è un concetto
estremamente importante dovrebbe
mitigare le emissioni dei gas serra
cioè di quei gas che rendono l'atmosfera
simile a una serra quindi più calda e
torniamo sul più di quello che dovrebbe
essere ci sono moltissimi dati
letterature sono tutti un po controversi
pensate a fare indagini a livello
comunque circa è stato contabilizzato
che nel mondo l'agricoltura così come
praticata adesso boot in atmosfera 5
miliardi di tonnellate di equivalenti di
co2 per anno pensiamo che le foreste
tropicali e riescono ad assorbirne un
miliardo e mezzo di tonnellate per darvi
un ordine di grandezza questi sono dati
della nasa di pochissimo tempo fa
quindi occorre fondamentale e mitigare
le emissioni
esistono delle forme jari agricoltura
climate smart si ne esistono
io qui vi ho portato un esempio di un
sistema che sta funzionando molto bene
in tutta italia che un sistema di
supporto agli agricoltori che è nato poi
qui in emilia romagna e poi si è diffuso
che fa arrivare ai agli agricoltori sul
loro cellulare
il consiglio irriguo per non consumare
acqua e quindi anche energia
conseguentemente loro sanno esattamente
da un sistema esperto che a
un'elaborazione offline su computer
quanta acqua e quando devono darla ai
loro appezzamenti
esistono poi i droni ne avrete
sicuramente sentito parlare che
permettono quella che si chiama
agricoltura di precisione volano sui
campi e per ogni metro di terreno
riescono a capire e indirizzarsi su che
cosa serve quindi se serve
antiparassitario se serve concime se
serve una lavorazione aiutano a mitigare
quindi mitigare come possono fare ad
esempio le aggiunte di certi additivi
vegetali a tale dieta dei bovini
permettendo di ridurre le fermentazioni
enteriche quindi le emissioni di
ammoniaca che un gas che ha un potere
riscaldante altissimo molto più alto
della co2
parlavamo di adattamento prima io ho
pensato di portarvi un esempio di
un'agricoltura climate smart che non sa
di esserlo e quella di un'isola l'isola
di pantelleria che proprio dall
agricoltura ricavato vita ricavato
turismo
essendo un territorio potenzialmente
ostile all'uomo perché c'è moltissimo
vento e ci sono pochissime piogge
il giardino pantesco che vedete li
racchiude delle piante di agrumi piante
di agrumi o arancio limone che sono il
simbolo dell'anarchia sicilia per i
primi colonizzatori dell'isola e sono
anche fonte erano anche fonte di
vitamine e li racchiude in un muro di
pietra vulcanica che è in grado di non
soltanto di frenare il vento ma di
rilasciare di notte il calore assorbito
di giorno e quindi tra l'altro
permettendo la condensa dell'acqua che
arriva con il vento dal mare rende
possibile la vita la sopravvivenza di
queste piante a pantelleria poi esistono
queste terrazzamenti di muretti a secco
fatti della stessa pietra vulcanica che
è la pietra dell'isola quindi non c'è
niente di portato da fuori che
proteggono tra l'altro negli anfratti di
queste pietre si celano i capperi
crescono bene anche questi vengono
venduti e commercializzati questi
muretti proteggono delle piante di vite
che sono votate al contrario votate per
invecchiare anziché per ringiovanire
quindi consumano meno acqua e quindi
questo per me queste piante ovviamente
producono il passito che un vino
estremamente importante e
è diventato un marchio importante ci
sono ditte e anche portato sul
territorio personaggi famosi che hanno
comprato e che investono sul territorio
quindi è un'isola rivitalizzata proprio
da un'agricoltura che tutto sommato ha
inglobato una forma antica di sapere non
necessariamente l'adattamento deve
venire da una tecnologia nuova ma può
venire anche dal recupero di vecchie
conoscenze che sono andate perdute o che
non vengono più considerati un altro
esempio si può essere smart in contesti
estremamente diversi questa signora si
chiama che il crude è rimasta vedova
nello zimbabwe si è dovuta trovare se
trovate a dover coltivare la terra al
posto del marito le di agricoltura
sapeva poco e niente però ovvero una
donna intelligente è una donna
intelligente non è morto è ascoltato la
radio e si è ascoltato le previsioni
stagionali metereologiche stagionali è
saputo più o meno una roba del genere
rielaborata ovviamente è saputo dove e
quando avrebbe piovuto ha saputo ha
scelto ha dedotto che cosa dove quando
seminare nella sua nella sua azienda
supportata però la sua fiducia nella
scienza è stata supportata da una
praticamente dal riconoscere essere
confortata dalla buona fioritura di
piante locali che tradizionalmente sono
auspici auspici di buoni raccolti e
quindi del through the senza saperlo
sola nel cuore dell'africa ha fatto
un'operazione climate smart così smart
che qua da noi ancora viene raramente
praticata quella di usare previsioni
stagionali a lungo termine per predire
delle rese quando queste previsioni
stagionali saranno veramente più
credibile si stanno lavorando moltissimo
sarà veramente estremamente utile
pensate poter poter programmare
lunga scadenza con buon anticipo le rese
di alcune culture importanti a livello
industriale come ad esempio il gran ecco
io vi ho fatto qualche esempio certo è
che la percezione da parte degli
agricoltori di come cambia il clima
varia enormemente a seconda del loro
luogo del luogo in cui si trovano delle
culture che praticano del anche the
ovviamente del loro grado di
preparazione tecnica sicuramente anche
se anche quelli più bravi hanno però il
diritto di essere supportati adesso
perché in questo mondo che spesso li
lancia anche sconcertati
credo abbiano diritto al trasferimento
di conoscenze trasferimento di buone
pratiche e quindi devono essere in
qualche modo aiutati questo è quello che
cerchiamo di fare noi ora con questi
progetti e questo è un progetto
importante ci abbiamo vari colleghi
l'inter è un progetto internazionale
supportato dal tali haiti e si chiama
climate smart agriculture booster quindi
booster come propulsore di tecniche
climate smart che noi lavorando sul
territorio e lavorando in collaborazione
a livello internazionale
cerchiamo di portare da un paese
all'altro cercando di migliorare e
favorire quindi li alle attività
produttive dei diversi agricoltori
questo lo facciamo e abbiamo aperto
l'anno scorso questo primo booster qua
in emilia romagna anche tra bologna e
sasso marconi dove il sindaco che qua
grazie sindaco cioè concesso spazio e
fiducia e in cui un luogo in cui non
riusciamo effettivamente a colloquiare
con gli agricoltori in un processo che
io definirei di co creazione un processo
che possiamo secondo me sintetizzare in
questo modo
impara dalle persone pianifica con le
persone comincia con quello che c'è e
poi costruisce su quello che si sa e
quando la missione compiuta le persone
ricorderanno che l'hanno fatto gasol
crediamo che in questo modo non solo io
ma anche i colleghi che
possa diventare smart il metabolismo
stesso dell'agricoltura e che
l'agricoltura continua a essere come
dicono un vecchio motto è una canzone la
nobile arte di coltivare i campi che
però abbia un piede nel passato e lo
sguardo rito è aperto nel futuro
vi ringrazio
grazie federica si trattengono ancora un
altro po stretta perché le curiosità di
un certo allora la prima è innovazione
agricoltura
vorrei sapere da te quale l'esposizione
delle donne all'informazione su queste
forme di innovazione sull'agricoltura
bella domanda dunque beh è bassa
l'espansione delle donne scarsa
soprattutto in molti paesi dove ho fatto
vedere quella signora pensiamo in africa
in africa il v m of a una serie di
seminari itineranti per gli agricoltori
in cui si va e si insegnano certe
pratiche agricole è solo il 3 per cento
delle presenze e femminile tra l'altro
queste signore che vanno vanno anche con
notevole sforzo perché devono convincere
il marito perché fanno fatica
socializzare a muoversi a spostarsi
spesso molte non hanno il cellulare
quindi più difficile e anche quando gli
avvisi vengono dati per tv o per radio
sono in giro magari per casa a preparare
la cena a badare ai bambini
beh da noi sicuramente diverso ci sono
tante donne imprenditrici anche però se
pensiamo guardiamo bene in campania
molte sono ad obbedire ai desideri del
marito e oppure al datore di lavoro e
quindi lavorano al livello un po più
basso
ok e poi ci fai un esempio di come si
possono superare queste barriere di
comunicazione la comunicazione siamo in
un luogo adibito alla comunicazione
credo che proprio sia sviluppare dei
linguaggi semplici che possono essere
percepiti ci sono paesi
noi adesso siamo abituati viviamo in un
mondo veramente che è completamente
alfabetizzato però ci sono posti nel
mondo dove molte persone non sanno
leggere né scrivere in india ci sono dei
gazebi che permettono alle persone di
andare e fare le domande in maniera
interattiva avere le risposte o mostrare
delle fotografie di foglie e malate e
sapere che tipo di trattamento cioè
quindi ci sono tanti modi di migliorare
la comunicazione
per renderlo forse un po più fluide
immediata grazie mille federica ti
salutiamo con un applauso